it's 1930 flemeth England and Henry L Stimson
arrives to join foreign delegates including
England's Ramsay MacDonald Stimson and MacDonald
or to see France refused to agree to parity
with Italy the invoice representing the United
States Great Britain and Japan were to announce
themselves in a cordon cruiser strain a decision
Stimson brought back with him when he returned on
the Leviathan by the terms of the agreement the
United States was to be allowed 18 heavy cruisers
as against 15 for England and profit Japan in
Washington Stimson reports to President Hoover
and on January 1st 1931 the United
States moves to fulfill its part
of the contract ships are dismantled
others are placed out of commission
as the Navy moves to comply with
its international armoring deal
cruisers like the Brooklyn of the Yorktown
veterans of the Santiago battle and a piloto
AR front by shellfire members of our first line
of defense all victims of a diplomatic bargain